[Musica]
buonasera a tutti vorrei condividere con
voi questa sera 5 lezioni che ho preso
dai miei pochi successi e dai miei molti
fallimenti e che ho sintetizzato in
questa frase che poi è il titolo del mio
intervento possa perdere per vincere che
per me è diventato il mio mantra
prima però vorrei raccontarvi una storia
una storia che accaduta a tre anni fa in
un pomeriggio di giugno
questa storia associata a questa
immagine ora voglio rassicurarvi non è
una storia di apparizioni e non vi
costringerò a recitare come l'ave maria
a meno che qualcuno non lo voglia è
invece una storia che inizia nel salotto
di casa dei miei genitori
ero seduta sul divano a un certo punto
mi sento dei rumori provenire dalla
camera da letto loro anni alzo con passo
svelto mi dirigo verso la stanza e li
vedo mio padre prendere qualcosa dal
cassetto metterselo in tasca richiedere
il cassetto poi lo vedo voltarsi verso
la porta e lì inizia a urlare assunta
assunta chiamava mia madre che un bacio
assunta assunta e continua ad urlare
finché non la trova in cucina e lì tutto
d'un fiato e le dice assunta ma posso
andare in comune a chiedere i soldi che
mi spettano
con questa le mostre il santino della
madonna di capocolonna scambiandola per
la sua carta d'identità e mia madre con
tono serio e come no ma portati anche
gesù cristo perché oggi per ricevere dei
soldi ci vuole solo un miracolo
e se vuoi ora tutti di corsa in comune
io tu il signore la madonna e che dio ce
la mandi buona
scoppiamo tutti a ridere incluso mio
padre ma sono certa non avesse capito
bene il perché ero tornata da crotone
dopo essere stato a modena e aver
vissuto a modena negli ultimi sei mesi
peggiori della della mia vita ero
vicepresidente di una società di
consulenza che avevo contribuito a
fondare
aveva una cattedra da docente
universitaria avevo un fidanzato con cui
conviveva e dopo sei mesi non avevo più
nulla neanche una casa per cui decido di
ritornare dai miei genitori in un
momento nel quale le condizioni di mio
padre malato di alzheimer stavano
peggiorando ma non passava giorno nel
quale io non mi tormenta si chiedendomi
perché tutte sfighe dovevano succedere a
me è perché tutte nello stesso istante e
vi confesso che non soltanto porta o
provavo vergogna per i miei fallimenti
ma provavo rabbia nei confronti di chi
mi aveva ferito disprezzo perché aveva
tradito le mie aspettative ma
soprattutto avevo paura di rimanere in
un limbo situato a chilometri di
distanza dai miei sogni fin che è la
reazione di mia madre nel rispetto ai
comportamenti divertenti stravaganti ma
anche capricciosi di mio padre
quel giorno e nei giorni a seguire mi
spinsero a chiedermi ma perché io stavo
affrontando i miei fallimenti come una
tragedia e quindi ho iniziato a pensare
come poter osservare i miei fallimenti
da una prospettiva diversa
la prima lezione che ho appreso e voglio
condividere con voi e questo qualsiasi
cosa osservata sotto un'angolazione
diversa assume un'altra forma un'altra
luce
perfino un altro significato
allora chi di voi condivide con me alzi
la mano condivide con me la frase ogni
scelta contiene un margine di errore e
ogni decisione in fondo è una scommessa
che non dà certezza chi di voi condivide
bene a tutti grande
ora se condividete con me questa frase
allora troverete assolutamente strano
che ogni volta che ci capita un evento
negativo che non avevamo mai immaginato
viviamo questa tragedia come uno
smarrimento
lo stesso che prova dante trovandosi
nella selva oscura dopo aver smarrito la
dritta via per un fallimento della sua
morale ma dante a differenza nostra ci
tiene subito a raccontare il bene che io
vi trovai invece un brutto voto un
licenziamento la fine di una relazione
sono vissute tutti come smarrimento e
proviamo soltanto frustrazione ansia
immobilismo anche per anni ed è
difficile vederne il lato positivo è
buono delle cose allora mi sono fatto
un'altra domanda
ma siamo proprio sicuri che quello che
io sto vivendo ora come un fallimento lo
sarà anche domani la fine della mia
relazione sentimentale era veramente una
catastrofe ora la necessità di trovare
canoni diversi per la mia felicità è la
fine del mio percorso professionale era
veramente un intoppo definitivo o una
semplice necessità di trovare una giusta
via ai miei desideri
mi sono domandata nuovamente se non era
il caso di come mia madre affrontare la
vita con un sorriso e soprattutto mi
sono chiesta ma perché ogni volta che di
fronte a un obiettivo non raggiunto
un'aspettativa disattesa a un sogno
infranto noi ci tormenti amo a farci
sempre le stesse domande sbagliate e
andare alla ricerca dei nostri perché
perché a me perché tutto quello istante
e quindi la seconda una lezione che ha
preso e che voglio condividere con voi
e questa una buona risposta non esce mai
da una domanda ma al posto
chi di voi ha un parente o un conoscente
malato di alzheimer
un bel po la cosa strana di questa
malattia e che voi
ieri siete una persona e oggi un'altra
mio padre adorava il caffè ora le doti è
stata per lui esistevano soltanto i
programmi sportivi sono il calcio era
tutti i giorni guardava maria de filippi
ascoltava di rado la musica è solo la
musica italiana
ora ero un fan sfegatato di lady gaga
per mia madre erano tutte eccezioni che
però non scalfivano la sua identità di
marito e di padre
mentre tutti quelli che lo conoscevano
facciamo fatica a riconoscerlo e
vedevano in tutte queste sue eccezioni
molta stranezza e tanta follia non avevo
riflettuto fino in fondo sul detto
l'eccezione conferma la regola
fino a quel momento seguitemi un attimo
che cos'è la regola la regola è tutto
ciò che per noi è normale convenzionale
da quindi giusto ma la regola crea un
confine oltre il quale colloca
l'eccezione e che cosa l'eccezione ciò
che non è normale ciò che non è
convenzionale
ciò che non è giusto quindi sbagliato e
se la regola quindi è una terra
conosciuta e confortevole
l'eccezione è una terra che ancora non
abbiamo calpestato e che ci fa paura ma
con venite con me che la frase
l'eccezione conferma la regola
in realtà illogica e mancante di un
pezzo perché l'eccezione conferma la
regola significa che l'eccezione non
scalfisce mai la regola non riesce a
smuovere la minimizza la cristallizza
non la cambia l'eccezione conferma la
regola
ci spinge a rimanere in una confortevole
sufficienza cisco raggio da lo sa e ci
costringe a pensare che esiste una
normalità che dobbiamo accettare e che
non possiamo mettere in discussione una
normalità socialmente accettata che non
ci spinge
ad uscire dai nostri confini perché
dobbiamo fare ciò che è giusto e ciò che
è normale convenzionale e quindi tutto
ciò che non è in questo flusso di
normalità che l'eccezione allora è
un'anomalia una deviazione una nota
stonata il successo la vittoria la
perfezione sono le nostre regole mentre
il fallimento di insuccesso
l'imperfezione solo le nostre eccezioni
e invece noi dovremmo assolutamente
utilizzare nella nostra vita un
principio scientifico che molto più
corretto ovvero l'eccezione conferma che
la regola è sbagliata se c'è
un'eccezione e la potete osservare
direttamente allora vuol dire che la
regola è sbagliata perché la regola non
è un dogma
non è una verità assoluta e come dice la
parola stessa
una guida e quindi ho detto mi ogni
volta soprattutto le donne tendono a
rimuginare così tanto sull'errore
pensandolo un'eccezione sbagliata vanno
invece dovremmo interrogarci sulla
giustezza della regola perché soltanto
quando infrangiamo la regola allarghiamo
i confini e scopriamo nuovi menti
soltanto quando infrangiamo la regola è
ancora tutto possibile
la terza lezione quindi che ho appreso è
che voglio condividere con voi e questa
fallimentare eccezione la tua nuova
regola
ora vi chiedo di fare un esercizio
insieme a me
sedetevi siete seduti a sette sedute
scusa state rilassati
chiudete gli occhi e iniziato a pensare
la vostra vita dal momento in cui siete
nati ad oggi vi lascio qualche secondo
continuate ad immaginare costruite
associate in maniera istintiva una forma
geometrica un'immagine un disegno alla
vostra vita quando faccio questo
esercizio con i miei studenti e mi corsi
quello che mi trovo di fronte in genere
sono questi disegni molto colorati come
vedete e differenziati bici ritrovate sì
allora qual è il problema di questo qual
è il problema di questi disegni e che in
realtà sono tutti i disegni in cui noi
osserviamo la vita la nostra vita con i
tratti fantasiosi ma non usiamo non
questi tratti non c'è l'idea del nostro
errore perché noi in realtà
immaginiamo la vita così particolare
quando in realtà la nostra vita
la viviamo così ovvero come una sequenza
di scelte razionali in questo in questo
caso l'errore è una possibilità che non
avevamo ancora immaginato un altro
esempio potrebbe essere questo
l'orologio voi sapete in ogni fase della
vostra vita dove siete dove sta andando
e questo un mondo lineare e semplice che
non conosce il caso di inaspettato e il
mutevole e invece è in realtà la nostra
vita è questa un caos ma se sul massimo
questo caos la nostra vita avrebbe
questa immagina ovvero un'alternanza di
salite e discese accelerate e frenate
cosa mi ricorda questa immagine ma il
battito di cuore
questa immagine è il suono del battito
del cuore e come vedete i punti di
minimo corrispondono alle fasi di
contrazione che forniscono e lo stimolo
per i picchi più alti
è in questa in questa immagine l'errore
è assolutamente contemplato perché
l'errore è questa la mia diciamo il mio
messaggio
l'errore è in realtà è qualcosa di
naturale perché senza alti e bassi nella
nostra vita
avremo questa immagine quindi la quarta
lezione che voglio condividere con voi è
questa la vita è complessa e l'errore
assolutamente ho fatto non soltanto
naturale ma addirittura necessario
perché l'unico modo che abbiamo io e voi
per imparare
l'errore infatti plasma il nostro
cervello modifica la struttura dei
nostri neuroni creando nuove inedite
connessioni ora qual è il problema
il nostro cervello è una mente
meravigliosa ogni volta che facciamo una
scelta
il nostro cervello ci segnala l'errore
in 80 millesimi di secondo
ma noi non lo percepiamo e allora quando
faccio una scelta e a seguito della
nostra scelta riceviamo un feedback con
brutto voto un licenziamento anche una
situazione appunto fallimentare cosa
accade
il nostro cervello si riattiva 2 è un
nuovamente i 250mila esimi successivi al
segnale ritorna e ci comunica che
appunto stiamo facendo un errore e mette
in atto subito dei meccanismi per
aiutarci a non sbagliare la prossima
volta per il cervello la storia dei
nostri fallimenti dello stirone e
finisce qui
no invece a volte serve una vita intera
per superare lo stigma di un fallimento
quanti di voi stanno pensando alla
relazione che è finita un anno fa e
quanti all'errore commesso nel 1982
l'incontro un sacco che mi ricordano
questa questa situazione e questo perché
perché ad un certo punto della nostra
vita e la soglia e si sta sempre di più
abbassando i nostri genitori
la società la famiglia inizia a
pretendere noi perfezione è successo e
questo crea nella nostra testa un forma
e lineare innaturale e ad ogni sbavatura
compare una ics rossa che credeteci
rimane in testa per per sempre è invece
quello che vi voglio dire che l'ultima
elezione che vi voglio condividere con
voi e che in realtà noi dobbiamo
assolutamente non soltanto accettare i
nostri errori ma dobbiamo premiarli e
condividerli dovete e questo è un
consiglio quando chiedete ai vostri
figli lo fate cosa è sbagliato perché lì
premiate
per il loro coraggio di osare e di
sperimentare tendenzialmente non si fa e
invece io vi invito a farlo perché
l'errore è la maniera più propriamente
umana di vivere e di imparare
ora se io dopo questo diciamo breve
speech
vi ha convinto e se da domani tutti
inizierete a fallire mi raccomando non
datemi lettere dall'avvocato
l'istigazione al fallimento cosa dicono
i ricercatori paradossalmente noi
impariamo di più dei nostri errori e
potremmo avere così risultati brillanti
perché perché l'errore è un atto di
innovazione è un pensiero rivoluzionario
e cibo sano per la nostra saggezza il
vero errore è quello da cui non
impariamo niente di noi stessi e del
mondo e soprattutto non impariamo a
niente dei nostri limiti delle nostre
potenzialità per cui io mi auguro che vi
auguro di errare ed imparare
solo così forse saremo migliori di ieri
trash
[Applauso]
[Musica]